[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record we talk about whatever
we got anthony back
anna dean with his brand new teeth hey
yo
does it look like super white on camera
because uh we just shot a video for
barbara and um
justin like because he does like crazy
like colors and stuff but the white
since it's the balance that
you're trying to go for white doesn't
change so it looks so [ __ ] bright and
fake
is that good that's bad it's bad because
that's the first view that came out with
the new teeth and everyone's like damn
those are white white
hell yeah are they just jealous though
they're probably yeah they glow in the
dark
that'd be have you seen those like some
people like
i think it was fake but they had the
tooth that had the the bottle opener
in it what how do you do that
i think it was like a fake video but you
know people like diamonds in their teeth
and stuff like that
you could do anything so like with this
it's like it's crazy because they last
like 30 years they feel like real teeth
they work like a rotate they're bonded
they can't pull them out they
they they should fall out but since you
could control it i picked the length of
my things and everything
i could have gotten super long if i
wanted cool anything i could have done
the color
dude that makes me want to do it because
i miss my canine what do you need it for
your teeth look great no because i i
cause i want the sharpness that's how
they used to be when i was little and i
thought they eat though
i thought they look so cool you don't
eat no because i don't have them that's
oh that's
wrong so you would eat more if you had
fangs i would get more meat
my natural fangs were longer than this
though yeah yeah
so because i i already had um fangs so i
was like let me still get them so i can
like
at least mimic my ulti your things are
sharp joe
they're sharpest you're the bottom ones
they're sharp yeah
bart's was pretty pretty long cases too
some of them uh some of my bottom ones
they got broken from too many fights so
my teeth aren't very even
they have a lot of chipped teeth yeah
they got popped in the mouth a lot
any any of you guys ever grind your
teeth at night i do not
see baby i do
when i did um gave me that same feeling
but molly
where you get that that good feeling
but it's like orgasms and when you
clench oh yeah i was like
i now i get it i don't do it but i'm
saying i get it
yeah no well every every night i always
i always grind my teeth and i remember
when i
i first started grinding in my teeth i
would wake up with like pieces of my
tooth in my mouth like little
chips of my teeth yeah it was pretty bad
i don't ever clench but they give you a
mouth guard because they're like if you
clench and stuff they could like like
regular teeth that will ruin
um mouth guard to work out with you
could work out with the dog if you do
they kept saying if you do sport i'm
like what sport like which one like
no i know what is sport and then uh but
they're like if you do like wrestling
and stuff like you you want to get like
a real mouth guard
um but this one's just like to sleep
with and if you do like basic activities
that you would clench normally
um it's not to protect like a punch but
it is to protect like just clenching
it's like a car cover
it's just for the pain yeah pretty much
and then uh so i got it but the thing is
it's it's formed to my exact teeth and
then
you wear it when you work out now no
we're just want to see because i don't
clench my mouth when i work out oh
uh but i started wearing it because i
now i started clenching
too many orgasms too many orgasms
at that ticket when i go to sleep so i
have crazy dreams but i wear it but it's
kind of like a retainer also
so it shifts the teeth and then when i
wake up my bite's a little off
oh just i feel like say like you you
have like braces right and then how many
of you have braces
yeah so you're supposed to wear a
retainer right because your teeth
naturally start going back
but you say like you haven't wore for a
year and you put it on it's gonna be
tight yeah
and then it's gonna start feeling
different in your mouth i can't even put
mine on my [ __ ] so [ __ ] up yeah
so come on on the next morning i'm
hurting
it's like you had braces all of a sudden
yeah yeah
so they were like where because they're
like your teeth are gonna constantly
moving
for the rest of your life and they're
gonna fit and they're gonna move and
adjust to how you bite and everything
because like the first
few days it was a little off um after
they already fixed it
but then now it feels the best so but
then they're like they're going to
continue to shift i'm like why just
because
they're fake like no just everyone's
teeth always shift and move
so i was like oh that's so crazy when
you guys get older
like old people old would you want to
get the removable dentures or like the
ones that are like stuck in your
fixed fixed yeah because i think it'd be
so fun to just be
like just because
why do you have to get dentures though
does your teeth fall out when you're old
i just never realized why like i think
you get enough cavities and then enough
root canals and they pretty much rot and
then so your teeth just start
like my mom i think like half of the
bottom is all fake now like they just
like if you just don't take care of them
back then they didn't have the good info
so even though they tried their best to
take care of it like a lot of old people
they just don't have their real teeth
yeah my grandpa had dense dentures and
he would take him out but he would like
close his jaw all the way up he looks
funny huh yeah it looks so like a turtle
yeah it was so fun you ever seen like
the half dentures though it's like not
the whole thing so like when the
people they take it out they're only
taking out like five or six teeth and
like a
a separator and then they still have
like my grandma had that
yeah oh it's like the guy from james
bond what did they get from james bond
that one was a little more intense that
guy like tried to choose cyanide and
then he pulled out like half the skull
and he was like
yeah you see what she did to me i
started screaming
my grandma had dentures but she also had
alzheimer's so
she lost all her manners so we'll be
eating like at a restaurant she just
pops it out and puts it in her tap water
and just starts oh
[ __ ] did you see this cloudy-ass water
i'm just looking at her like oh
god and she puts it back you think old
people like lose manners you think they
just stop giving a [ __ ] though you know
yeah because that when you're into being
a child the older you get i think
right it's i think that it's cooler like
that
yeah i don't actually give a [ __ ]
anymore but it's like
yeah i don't know there's also other
people eating yeah so you just see all
this like but like a child it's like
it's like you're gonna yell at a kid
it's like you yell at me
you really yummy it's a joke that nick
schwartzen did that he was like when he
gets older he's like gonna act cuz like
they shoot you like a baby and like you
act like you forget so like he was gonna
be like he'll say like his grandson's
birthday he's just gonna send him a box
of [ __ ]
right and be like thinking like is that
what's in it because like
people can't get mad you at that point
right they're just like oh [ __ ] he's all
like what are we gonna say
and he's just playing a trick the whole
time yeah yeah that's what i would do
if i had my memory drastic that's not
even something that you would
accidentally do you know like a sending
a box no but like if you're see now
oh yeah yeah okay well c now is a new
variable
yes you know oh we didn't talk yeah yeah
you lost your mind it's a bit of both
right there it is yeah what's the
difference c now
alzheimer's or joe
forgetfulness the thing is like if joe
starts going a little like wonky i
wouldn't
know starts going
yeah like if if the act drops and it
ends up being real
we wouldn't think it's not an act right
or like if joe started just acting
normal
what's that mean to you what's that what
is normal
i think first uh you know the solar
powered sunglasses would come off
oh [ __ ] we're starting to feel weird
like be wearing like socks and shoes is
joe the craziest guy
is joe the craziest guy everybody's
shoes nah no no i think he's just
consistently on the outside though
i feel comfortable what's the difference
between outside am i more normal now
will you cover your eyebrows
it's way less assuming somebody walks in
now though they're not going to
be able to pick the weird person out of
the bunch maybe him but
the flowers before just a shiny scene
perfect
just smiling at them but just before
like one minute ago for sure
he's the weird guy but i feel
comfortable on joe when he's himself
yeah absolutely you feel like they're
just dancing i feel
normal when i'm not dancing is when you
should worry
yeah you're not fidgeting it's like wait
what's just like when you have a toddler
right
right part when your toddler stops
making oh yeah
you start getting worried yeah if you
just came in and you saw tyka sitting on
the couch just like staring at the tv
just normal
i'd be freaked out normal like watching
the news yeah
and he's like can you believe he's off
it's on that that's
crazy for anyone that's not normal daddy
did you see the man in the tv
that's [ __ ] scary like if taika was
like um
no like i don't want the dessert give me
food first and i'll eat the dessert
after it
that's when you'd probably be like what
the [ __ ] especially a kid like him
because he's crazy too
can you can you believe if we watched if
you looked at your phone he goes daddy
can you believe the [ __ ] dow jones
right now is
going under what the [ __ ] i think bar
would be happy i would that would be
awesome teach me some [ __ ] please teach
me about like stewie if there's an adult
inside my child and i'm like where did
you put my child [ __ ]
i know right give me my child back
that's scary would you rather be like a
like a in a child's body with your mind
right now or like in a group like a
grandpa's grandma you get to do you get
to grow old
yeah as a child no i think it's a
one-week experiment
one week one week just one week you got
it oh it's way better to be a
child because an old person doesn't
matter oh people don't matter no but in
terms of you can't do
the mercy of whoever your parents
whereas an old person
you can still call some shots no but you
go to okay you'll be in a child right
they would consider you a child prodigy
if you act like this at a child but it's
only a week and then
you forget what you're gonna have more
fun with i think a child
yeah because it's like you know you
you're going to be able to
you're going to have a lot of time as a
grandpa one day or grandma
right so you're going to get there
eventually but then being a child
again with the adult mind yeah
but you don't know if you're going to be
an old person with the mind you have now
because it deteriorates as you get older
so
you wouldn't even have yeah you wouldn't
even have the i kind of i kind of would
want to choose the
old body just because like all the stuff
that they teach you right like you know
when you're a kid brush your teeth
you're gonna get cavities and then when
you're a kid you're like what the [ __ ]
are cavities
and then later on when you're like oh
that's why they wanted me to brush my
teeth so like all the stuff that they
still tell us to do
now i'm like man [ __ ] you but then if
i'm in a 70 year old body then maybe i
can experience like
oh that's why i am supposed to like
drink that much water
i'm supposed to do and then that way i
could actually know what's legit right
now
very experienced because it's the
officer you should do it now
no but none of us are no but you don't
really do it he's he's seeking the
wisdom without needing the experience
none of us are doing it now because
none of us none of us have learned a
lesson right you should i feel that
lesson now
my knees hurt i can't move as good like
i have to put my lessons you would know
and learn
if you were old like all this stuff that
you didn't it's funnier to [ __ ] with
people imagine you're three years old
and you see a couple of arguing and you
guys guys like it's not it's not
important
like what you got to fight yeah but then
you also got to like take 10 minutes to
get there you're like
yeah yeah and can you can you speak
though okay
can you speak as a kid because like the
thing the thing that's in my mind is
like
you might have the mind that we have now
but can your does your
mouth move the way like it does and can
you even articulate what you want to
articulate as a
as a baby well how old are we talking
kid or a baby what do you think three
he said taika three three works well
taika is about to be three
and a half months he can he works pretty
well he can say a few words there's a
lot of words like today he says
you chirp me cute you gotta say hurt he
said your church
church what could you really do at that
age to show that you're
smart that's all you care about math
cause for me i wouldn't care about
like proving to other people that uh
what would you want to do
well you probably do what you you do
right now probably like buying some
crypto
with your brain now though it would
probably be frustrating because you
can't
connect and use your body the way you
want to
yeah oh with either one huh what if
yeah with either one technically with
would you
i mean would this situation be at the
time of when you were a child you're
going back to your child your own
child's body
or is it present time in a random
child's body
or and oh also just conceptual child
or conceptual old person versus your
childness
yeah like your own history or your
possible future like
is it man if you give me a chance to go
back in time
but before you answer this awesome
question this video is brought to you by
upstart and you know kids are expensive
as hell right yes they are
yeah you gotta watch out and sometimes
you just can't
get the loans that you need and all that
stuff but unlike other lenders upstart
can reward you based on your education
and job history
in the form of a smarter rate you don't
need a degree or diploma
to apply though yeah start lets you skip
going to the bank because it's
completely
online yup awesome and they offer loans
from 1 000
all the way up to 50 000
so you can consolidate all your debt
into one easy fixed rate payment which
is really important because if you have
too many payments all different
interest rates it's really hard to get a
hold of your financial situation
they make it fast and simple to check
your rate since it's just a soft pull
it won't affect your credit school the
hard pull happens if you accept your
rate and proceed with your application
and the best part if the loan is
approved and accepted
most people get their funds the very
next business day which is really really
fast
so over 400 000 people have used upstart
to pay off credit cards
for meeting their financial goals so
free yourself from the burden of high
interest credit card debt and get back
to using your money your way with
upstart and see why upstart has 4.9 out
of five
rating on trustpilot and hurry to
upstart.com
record r-e-c-o-r-d to find out how low
your upstart rate can be
that's right checking array only takes a
few minutes that's upstart.com
record i just realized though
that like even if i'm smart as a kid if
i go back and i want to pull like a
upstart loan like they won't even give
me the time of day so you could be smart
but then like they're looking at you
like a kid that's what i'm saying
the old person has more access can't buy
a house yeah old person's got access
is there a law people just do like drugs
because they can't do anything else you
know what i mean so it's like yo
you get senior discount yeah but is
there a law is there a law though if
you're old that you can't get like a
mortgage or a loan or whatever
because it's like there's there are i
mean if you get a 30-year fix
right come on you ain't gonna survive
that long you got like two more years on
you you can't be 99 trying to get life
insurance
[Laughter]
dude well you can't be three-year-old
trying to get life insurance for
yourself either it's gonna be super
super high
high rates no but um like a million
dollars a month
know what i mean like i think that's
that's ageism i think it's illegal
really yeah because because there's like
100 year old people
still driving remember that one person
they shouldn't maybe
i know but like they're still driving
it's crazy yeah because my um
parents can't get a loan out in japan
oh really because of their age yeah
because of their age they don't have
aegis laws
because they'll be like come on dude
you're like in your 80 like how are you
going to get a 30-year fix you're
you're 80. but in japan they lived to
like 115
and [ __ ] yeah but 30 years plus 80 you
know
that's true though is that ageism
because that's like uh it's kind of
realistic
it's a yeah it's an investment it's like
here your shelf life for this
investment is drastically yeah shorter
than
maybe you have to prove somehow actually
yeah i don't know
you're like my parents lineage my
grandparents all lived to 168.
yeah no no it's hereditary age i meant
prove that you can pay back but it's
like yeah how can you
i'm for sure going to hit 170. i got
time they could get rentals
you know because it's like yeah you'll
live another month you know to me
i got these jokes from a mom though
she's joking about [ __ ] like this you
know like she's fine
with her age but it to me it's funny
because
i was like wait do they have that in
america too where you can't get a
home loan or other things it does make
sense though but
who's getting mad about that who's
getting triggered like is the old people
probably because they're like
[ __ ] you i'm healthy just because i'm
i'm 83
and i'm still running marathons and [ __ ]
like [ __ ] you like i'm going to live
okay it took you this long to buy a
house yeah i'm trying
maybe it's like their seventh house or
something you don't know well then they
should have the money for
it this is true i'm totally trying to
pull loans when i'm super old and i'm
hoping i'm like as many as possible yeah
if i don't have kids
i'm going in debt for sure i'm dying in
debt i think you're gonna have kids
no i'm just saying like life you know
you can't just i'm like for sure gonna
have kids i don't know you know that's
just what it is
but i tell you what if i have no kids
and i not only pass on and i'm like
65 plus yeah i'm down to getting debt
when i die i for sure want to [ __ ] with
people
like in a good way so definitely when
you die yeah oh
so like i want to like okay hopefully i
don't die like before like i get old
but like if i know i'm gonna die like
like i'm old i'll record some videos to
play at my funeral
i'd be like here's a treasure map i hit
i hit some
some buried treasure and i'll put it up
to the world is it gonna be like real
treasure or not
oh just like the guy that did it
whatever the [ __ ] yeah i like that guy
it's a
either real one or i'll plot those loans
and i'll bury the loans in the
as if there's real treasure that's not
[ __ ] with people that's giving them
opportunity
yeah i just want some something for
people to remember me
remember oh there's a story later on
today
you just need a statue that's it you're
just gonna like when you die in your
casket everything's gonna deter it but
your teeth are gonna
[ __ ] look at that grill
i mean your bone stays no matter what
yeah i'm just saying it's crazy because
they took the x-ray right
nicest teeth as a skeleton all your hair
is just gonna like kind of fall down
because your skin's gone but your hair's
next to your teeth and you're like
that's that's gonna be part of the
treasure map find your teeth yeah
but when they took the exercise inside
your teeth so that's the thing it's like
you know when people have gold teeth
that's what they used to do back in the
day it's like i had to cover it right or
to put an implant
right yeah yeah that's crazy it's like
real gold
but then sometimes like the the stuff
that you got all in your mouth is like
silver it's like a powerful [ __ ]
mercury you have ceramic in there
yeah it's mercury oh mercury yeah i got
lead and [ __ ]
lead all of it i forgot no yeah i think
it's lead i thought they're replacing
them with the porcelain or whatever
you have to pay for that no but now
because that's they know it's harmful
that was something back in the day yeah
we're already screwed
no i got mine taken out we are already
screwed yeah yeah
yeah for sure wait your entire tooth is
silver
that's aesthetic though the black one
that kind of reminds me of joe pesci
from home alone you know he smiles yeah
yeah that's why i should have taken a
gold one i
already knew what is it should have had
a goal you gotta choose
yeah yeah you could choose but i was
like 15 at the time it's like a silver
two
you didn't want first place huh
porcelain one which is thank you so bad
i didn't even go there dude god damn it
you went there
wait what are you missing i was just
thinking about gold silver and i was
like oh he didn't even want first place
but then he brought it he brought it
back to the [ __ ] tv show
you brought it back i just said thank
you
it'll never end it will never end god
damn it dude
[Music]
you